okay dann versuche ich es mal
mit einem persönlichen Gedicht
und hätte ich einen Wunsch in Not
so wünschte ich mir einen Freund
und wenn ich sonst auch viel nicht braucht so
bräuchte ich einen Helfer ein guter Schäfer
der stets wacht und übles abzuwenden der jedes
Schaf zu hüten weiß egal wie tief gebräunt wer
alles tat für Tag durchstreift um Unheil zu
beenden der mit Geschick und rechtem Fleiß
den ganzen Hof umzäunt und alles wie gilt
ihm als gleich ob Bullen Schweine Kälber
sie haben es natürlich genau richtig erkannt
es handelt sich hierbei um klassisches
Biedermeier Gedicht mit siebenhebigen Lampen
im Reimschema a b c A C A b oh Gott oh Gott
ganz ganz blöder Zufall ja also ich distanziere
mich vom rheinschema ACAB also sowas zu sagen
wie wie all Cops a Bastards das geht gar nicht ne
das ist das ist das selbe also wenn man sagt all
Cops a Bastards ist es dasselbe wie wenn man
sagt alle Ausländer sind kriminell also sowas
machen nur Bastarde basta so also die Polizei ist
natürlich mein Freund und Helfer aber es ist eine
recht einseitige Freundschaft die Polizei ist
jetzt nicht die Art von Freund die Bananenbrot zu
deinem Spieleabend mitbringt und ihr beim Umziehen
hilft es ist eher die Art von Freund die ungefragt
bei deinem Geburtstag auf Kreuz und die Party
beendet wenn es am schönsten ist es ist auch so
ein Freund einfach kein Spaß versteht ne ich bin
mal bei einer Polizei Kontrolle gefragt worden ob
ich noch Restalkohol habe ich gesagt ja klar ich
habe noch einen halben Asbach auf dem Rücksitz
Greifzug Kumpel fand da nicht lustig ich habe
auch eine Regel Brieffreundschaft mit der Polizei
da kann ich gerne drauf verzichten die
melden sich nur wenn die Kohle sehen wollen
ich weiß auch gar nicht warum die unbedingt
mit mir befreundet sein wollen wirklich ne also
vielleicht liegt es an meinem exotischen Look ich
weiß es nicht bin letztes Jahr mit dem Zug nach
Südtirol gefahren und hatte den exotischsten Look
im Abteil durch die Polizei gekommen haben wir
erstmal meine Koffer auseinandergewühlt und
der munter in meiner Unterwäsche rumgekramt
gedacht okay das geht jetzt ein bisschen
über normale Freundschaft hinaus Leute
das ist jetzt und sowas wie Freundschaft plus
eigentlich geht's ja jetzt beim dritten Date
an die Wäsche auf der Rückfahrt war ein
schwarzer mit mir im Abteil haben sie
mich in Ruhe gelassen und in seiner Unterwäsche
rumgewühlt da war ich ein bisschen eifersüchtig
ja ich weiß es ist kompliziert mit der Polizei
wirklich wahr ich bin ja froh dass es Menschen
gibt die diesen Job machen ich würde es
nicht machen wollen um Gottes Willen ich
bin ich bin auf ich bin mir sicher die
meisten von ihnen sind rechtschaffende
Menschen mit den besten Absichten deswegen
versuche ich es jetzt noch mal mit einem
persönlichen Gedicht ich habe diesmal auch das
Reimschema unter Kontrolle das ist nämlich a
wenn du draußen einen kiffst kommt die
Polizei wenn du nachts nicht leise bist
kommt die Polizei wenn du dir was
schmeißen willst kommt die Polizei
und wenn reich und weißt du bist kommst
du wieder frei danke schön [Applaus]
dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug